on vous montre cette photo c'était pris
il y a quelques semaines vous rappelez
on l'annonce à la à la présidente de la
RATP les amis les jeux de mots sur la
RATP Jean Castex sur la bonne voie
Jean Castex sur de bons rails c'est fini
normalement hein
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas les derniers pour la galéjade
ça colorie
c'est de la com ouais il préparait déjà
ce plan et ça c'est pas bien et ça veut
dire que s'il avait fait d'auto
tamponneuse il aurait été pas trop
d'accord du trône la question il
cherchait la nomination qu'il a obtenu
pourquoi il veut cette nomination ça a
l'air annuel 450 000 euros 37000 euros
mensuel c'est le maximum pour une
entreprise de l'État je trouve que c'est
pas bien de recaser comme ça un ancien
Premier ministre qui a ourdi son truc
avec le président il a oublié il a
préparé c'est un plan de longue date
c'est mépriser les
usagers de la RATP je suis en colère
contre lui j'irai pas aussi loin que
Gilles moi comme d'habitude
non mais je le crois effectivement
sincère quand il dit qu'il prend le
parce qu'il a révoqué son personnel il
est il a plus de chauffeur il a plus de
voiture il a plus de garde du corps etc
et alors qu'il y avait droit en tant que
voilà ministre et je pense effectivement
ça date pas d'hier maintenant qu'ils
prennent le le métro maintenant le fait
qu'elle soit sortie un mois avant la
nomination on peut effectivement se
poser des questions en disant il y a là
il y a là une interrogation anonyme vous
êtes beaucoup trop naïf il faut nous
prendre clairement pour des cons tu peux
leur dire d'arrêter de déménager là-bas
là
c'est insupportable merci on nous prend
pour des cons ça fait des semaines qu'on
voit plusieurs photos parce
qu'effectivement il y en a plusieurs de
photos de gens cassés dans le métro qui
recycle qui circule on se dit enfin
politique proche des gens on était les
premiers à s'en réjouir sur ce plateau
et là on découvre qu'en fait on nous a
complètement dupé tout ça c'était une
mascarade c'était un énorme coup de com
depuis le début donc ça envoie encore un
signal que les politiques nous
manipulent et nous prennent pour des
cons c'est horrible est à chier quand
même bah oui c'est nul franchement la
comète dans quelle émission le mec
s'arrête il dit oh c'est pas fini
il est tellement fou qu'il est capable
de se marrer d'aller les voir en plus
non mais je vous jure je l'ai vu son œil
de niveau comme ça
ils sont en train de déménager on en
parle sur le plateau excusez-moi sur
téléspectateurs il y a des gaz sans
déconner tu as l'impression qu'il y a un
déménagement bah c'est des ouf les gars
sérieuses ouais c'est bon ou quoi bordel
bon qu'est-ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs c'est ça qui m'intéresse
oui 78 %. non pas de 1%